hi there steve here continuing on my
90-day korean challenge and today i want
to talk about language learning
frustrations
because there are lots of frustrations
in language learning it kind of goes
with the territory
different people have different
frustrations
one of my frustrations is that feeling
you know that we're in what i would call
the doldrums
we're in this boat and there's no wind
we're not moving we have a feeling that
we're kind of not progressing as quickly
as we would like
um
every day i plow through content i
listen i read
another frustration is i don't have
enough time
you know as it is if i get in today i
think i got in two hours
i shouldn't say that i don't feel i'm
improving because i do feel that i'm
able to read through the content much
more quickly than before i get the gist
of of all of the constructions in korean
but i still have trouble understanding
when i listen so that's again a little
bit of frustration if you want i guess
the biggest frustration is that i don't
have enough time
uh my wife had her operation foot
operation so she's got this great big
boot on her foot she can't put weight on
it she has to have her foot up all the
time so i do all the cooking all the
cleaning everything and we eat well like
last night i i made a soup
out of parsnips
uh kabucha which is like a japanese
pumpkin and potato which i boiled and
then
munged it and added some chicken stock
and that was our soup
and then i had
a salmon
uh no no actually no last night i had my
gran my daughter-in-law's stew left over
from the other evening so we had that
but tonight i got to make a salmon
um what else did i make we had some
beans that i saw in the fridge so i uh
and the potatoes left over from the
other night when we had the stew we're a
little bit tired so i mixed them with
the beans a little bit of olive oil and
some parsley
uh what else did i do oh yeah we had
some salad that was starting to work so
we have to eat the salad and some old
broccoli so i boiled up the broccoli
threw it in cold ice cold water and
threw the broccoli guys
into my salad
i mixed the salad dressing and bring all
that kind of stuff and then i got to
clean up i mean it all takes time
and you know i can clean up while
listening to korean more difficult to
cook while listening to korean because
you actually have to think about what
you're doing
so that's the frustration
obviously if i had the opportunity to
meet with some koreans once a day a
lunch group or once a week or twice a
week it injects some novelty
speaking online is okay but i think in
any kind of a speaking situation i like
it to be natural meaningful
if i have the feeling that
i'm just talking to someone for the sake
of creating conversation that doesn't
turn my crank whereas if i have a group
of cronies
uh koreans that i met
once or twice a week and we just talked
about whatever
including the latest in korean politics
like this
sad fad
sad the controversy that i'm learning
about
that would be good that would stimulate
me a bit so
frustrations the feeling that we're not
moving along as quickly as we would like
but it's a long road and i know that so
i say frustrations in fact i don't get
frustrated more than anything i'm
frustrated by my continuing elevated
inability to understand
well when i'm listening
uh
but the only thing to do
when
we face these frustrations is to be
you know
remember again how many times i've
overcome these problems in other
languages so i just have to stay
with the program somebody here asked the
question you know what do i do i
understand these words and then when i
go to use them i can't remember them of
course you can't remember them and you
just have to be confident that
eventually things will fall into place
and eventually they do but it does take
a long time so you know i have to put
out a video every day or i
told myself i would
not much changes from day to day
and very often in language learning you
know we expect quick results we don't
get them but then we kind of
underestimate how much we improve over
the long haul so stay with it stay with
the task and you will be rewarded and so
will i i hope bye for now